yeah he has played money for which is uh
you know something that has been doing
his entire career so not not so far not
even an attempted Berlin
um uh yakhan says Wesley played Berlin
has he against
maybe there was a Berlin somewhere yeah
just to remind ourselves which line that
was but so today seems like a very very
solid round in general we have a lot of
uh Lions chosen by black which have a
very uh very stable reputation and not a
particular reputation for fireworks two
bedrooms a Nancy Berlin honestly I
depending on how this goes from here but
you get the feeling you know how this
goes from here yeah yeah I feel like uh
we need to this is uh yeah this is I
think he firmly believes he has
something here I don't think he does
this just because he is bored of all the
Humane like theory in the Petrov I think
uh these lines
uh are you know to a degree exactly what
he likes about Chess these kinds of you
know queenless middle games where uh
there are a lot of finesse perhaps
required in in some cases and you do
have to be precise you do have to
understand exactly what you're aiming
for we have to work out how we got here
because uh it's just it's a seemingly
random kind of selection of moves there
must be something yeah he played C6 uh
Magnus went with F3 mother six and D4
which is something that you generally I
think want in these types of positions
F3 is a very useful move uh very much
limiting the squares with Madonna F6 and
then we go on G4 and then either C3 or
as we will see in the game maybe even C2
C4 uh record goes H5 here which having
played Bishop 5 I think is a logical
move because I think White
will actually very heavily play G4 and
H4 if the bishop is left there
uh and this plan is unchallenged so H5
is useful just to make sure it survives
on this diagonal
Knight C3 Knight A6 king of two and
Richard kind of played himself into a
situation where
um if you take on itsu I think I would
make an argument that this is not
slightly worse for black because we've
gotten C4 D4 against c66 instead of a
very symmetrical C3 G4 against c65
uh H5 is
useful but also if you imagine some
position like this
it also gives white a very decent Square
on G5 to aim the bishop at
and your pieces just make sort of less
sense than White's pieces too
which is why he played Knight before I
guess just to keep the tension and also
create a third of my knight C2 and now
the Queens have stayed on yeah no more
standoff Mexicans can't stand off
between the Queens but whose King is
gonna be safer I'm assuming at this
point that Black's gonna cost a queen
side I don't really see it looks like it
yeah how's the king so I don't like this
for black very much I think you have to
play this if this is to work out for
Richie his next few moves need to be
very very precise Bishop takes G5 I
might have some tactics yeah
pretty much never works I think yeah
this is a way to lose uh long castles in
the meantime on the board unsurprisingly
so rookie eight yeah and you you're
threatening Knight E3 Bishop G5 as we've
established is not great so the way to
play here would be a kind of a really
awkward move like in YouTube and then G4
is coming in yeah okay so I mean these
kinds of questions that he has to solve
and he might just be in time
this is what this one will not be a
recurring segment of uh Force David to
name a computer line because I think
this one is difficult uh and will not
like my my asking the question will not
be enough of a help okay uh but for a
second there on my screen the best line
blackhead here apparently was D5 and
very specifically G5 everything else
white is like significantly better oh
wow that's not obvious C5 and then
Bishop D3 Bishop D3 and Knight E4 check
uh I honestly still still don't know why
this works I guess the point is fe4
Queen F6 check and you don't have good
squares the danger is and record in the
meantime has played D5 so wow
potentially very exciting stuff coming
up
yeah I if you told me to look for a
computer move I would have thought oh
it's going to be something weird like A5
no I I think I think like you would once
again name it in one second if I stopped
here and ask you to make the move yeah
but that's a bit that's a bit yeah uh
like asking you to get there from here I
think is a bit unfair and D5 makes a lot
of sense but it makes sense to play
concretely otherwise you've just given
white uh the clamp with C5 Bishop F4
coming so yeah so this is the point
exactly that if if once again if you if
you suddenly switch back to the sort of
sedate compliant mode
some positions like this could just be
borderline unplayable Rook H1 coming in
and then you just get mated after before
B5 comes in yeah uh so if you play D5
you have to do it with a very concrete
plan in mind otherwise C5 is just going
to be uh crushing this strong but this
yeah this does look very playable for
black after Knight takes D3 in this in
that specific position yeah takes takes
because after GE if you go a feed once
again you go six I mean this just kind
of loses right because everything
collapses Bishop takes C5 also a threat
yeah very hard where I see five yeah we
thought there was really no other choice
so we were expecting for this to happen
and now Bishop d394 does feel you know
like it's a very very critical attempt
which we don't know exactly how to
evaluate as far as I'm concerned two
players who are definitely not having a
particularly glorious tournament so far
and would very much both of them I think
like uh a win and I think currently I'm
I think Magnus has a much better chance
of uh getting that win
uh we left it here and as expected
Richard did land on an idea of 94 check
but it looks like he maybe did not use
the absolute best sequence uh he played
Knight takes D3 I think we like Bishop
takes E3 slightly better and also the
engine light which takes you slightly
better Bishop takes 94 check f e d b two
queen F6 we actually had it on the
screen before going on break
yeah and the game continues exactly as
we expected it would continue from here
wow Magnus played Bishop B3 which like
what else do you even play in this
position it looks so natural yeah and we
could play Bishop takes C5 and also what
else do you play in this position but as
a matter of fact
as I understand this position a lot
revolves specifically around the idea of
frugal fan King G1 okay and white really
should have started with Rook of funk
here and if Rook takes D4 you go Queen
E1 Bishop takes C5 which P3 and this is
the setup by what you want but you want
it like the more crucial part of this
setup is getting Rook of one king G1
rather than playing hp3 and white is
supposedly better in this position which
I think you can very easily believe
because I will play King G1 I'll play
Queen G3
things start coming out I think it's not
difficult to Imagine by being better
here the trickier part I think is why
Bishop 3 Bishop takes C5 is not the best
reply starting with Bishop B6 check here
was I think preferable to uh what
Richard has done and let's say after
King takes Giovanni Play Bishop takes C5
here I guess with the intention of doing
of doing this which is quite beautiful
in its own way really did not believe in
his prospects of holding some kind of a
technical position so he went for a
Gamble
he played clinics for checking G1 Bishop
D6 uh
which more or less forces like to play
root text F5 but I don't think white is
very worried about that the king will go
to F1
and then yeah I just don't know how
we're supposed to give mate to it I
guess he wants queen H2 King F1 king
queen H1 Bishop G1
page two
but then you kind of resign against king
of two right
yeah you're running out of pieces
running out of checks yeah I don't see
it does he want something with I can say
maybe instead of Bishop H2 on the last
move something with G6 just to annoy the
white Rook hoping for Rook takes F7 Rook
f8 at least yeah we're definitely not
not opening the f file uh for Blackwell
entirely I don't think but let's just go
Rook F6 for now yeah he should have
plenty of squares yeah and in fact
Bishop H2 always met by King F2 yeah H4
H3 is never like it's just giving white
additional squares for pieces and no
this just honestly just looks like
you're it don't see it you're very very
far behind should we fight you just take
on E5 and oh yeah I'm very happy giving
up some material yeah we're two with two
pieces up and
uh we just need to avoid some checks
which don't really appear lethal at all
it feels like he wanted to go down in
flames he realized that maybe he'd made
a rash decision already and uh or maybe
an accurate decision
it'll be interesting to see what he says
about uh kind of going into that other
line where he was just upon down with a
very stable position rather than this
peace sacrifice which turned into two
pieces and uh yeah I mean this is not
very enjoyable but it's definitely
playable for Blacklist p7 and looking
King jiwan rook he8 and yeah maybe lost
very soon I I don't see him play on too
much unless he can find something in the
next two or three moves and Bishop G1
okay Magnus is thinking of King F2 I
guess the fact that he's paused but King
I don't think he oh he's not on the
board somehow all right he is not I mean
he is what what are we missing here
why would that be oh uh you mean Magnus
thinking about King F2 or no Kingston is
just a Perpetual right yeah yeah exactly
Kings to finish four we have to go back
like there's no way where uh we're doing
that so Bishop G1 yeah I don't see what
we're missing
um feels like Magnus just checking his
lines
she's six we're gonna have six yeah
weirdly after Rook F6 Bishop H2 yeah
once again I've uh King F2 there is for
some reason this is this is different I
guess E3 check is stronger for some ah
whoa
yeah eventually the wish 107 does get
lost but in in in the meantime white
just stabilizes very very comfortably uh
like push page two we go king of two
take Stakes Rook f8 Queen B3
and black
eventually attacks it in such a way that
it gets picked up but we will have just
a very healthy
extra opponent extra Knight on C3 in
these types of positions a bit of time
on Rook takes F7 but not too long I
think this was the explanation for the
pause between before Bishop G1 he
realized G6 existed so he spent some
time here calculating it but now he is
blitzing stuff out this is the current
position
uh which we
assume is just winning yeah uh for him
should we try and see how Rapport can
even fight on otherwise we might see a
quick result
um no I think I think the line I showed
is the best the best
see how to pick up that white piece uh
to at least
two you take on F7 and go Rook of faith
will be three you take take you play
greenish for check and then you play
kind of oh no but that doesn't quite say
I play King E2 here yeah yeah because
you always have kunisics
yeah and then queen of four check and
then it's been takes of seven or
something but and I have to read
something out because yeah
I assume rookie one is the best 92 also
looks fine but why is six checks maybe
as well yeah why not just try to
oh yeah Queen E6 as well there's 26 pin
takes E4 why not yeah an f37 then you
play the key one or 92 or 92 yeah rookie
one looks best actually yeah just just
pick it up
um
yeah Magnus uh his technique is more
than good enough for this one he plays
Knight E2 immediately he's also very
sensible I think I think he just knows
he will win this so he is not really
very interested in you know finessing it
past a certain point which I think is
fair enough it does look very winning
I'm a bit surprised he did not try to
win leave for Pawn straight away because
both of them as we're discussing yeah so
uh in that position after 92 Richard
played between a five emergency went up
in H3 and uh yeah
uh Richard not very interested in trying
to defend this it's not really very
defendable
he doesn't really like wasting anybody's
time so
I assume after 92 you could maybe keep
the Queens on but the result still isn't
really very much endowed kuna Fife is
another one of those moves where it
feels like you've sort of checked out
you you no longer care about whether it
takes you five minutes or an hour and a
half here because you know what the
result is